foreign
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
qna segment January something or rather
January 21st yes third of the way
through winter yes we are hell yeah
third of the way through winter that's
something yeah we made it it is a third
of the way seasonal talk seasonal weed
talk I can do today
math talk wasn't working
we are going to spend an hour answering
your questions we're going to start with
the question from the Discord server
where the people on the Discord vote
every week on what question they most
want us to answer and we start there and
we're going to make the kitty cat a
little bit more visible somebody's a
little camera shy
there we go this is Tesla
I was very tired
book related question on the appendix
you discussed the hypothesis the
appendix is a safe house for the gut
Flora that repopulates the gut with good
gut Flora after gastrointestinal illness
and the appendicitis could be the result
of Western Lifestyles that make diarrhea
relatively rare
this seems to suggest that occasionally
inducing diarrhea might be good for our
health thoughts
I admit that this is not something that
had occurred to me before
I think
um if you are just thinking about the
health of the appendix
the answer might indeed seem to be yes
but there are other harms from diarrhea
that aren't incorporated into the
analysis yet and I don't know
all of the known harms and we certainly
none of us know what the unknown to us
yet uh harms of diarrhea are one of them
is one that most
modern westerners can deal with which is
losing you know losing the nutrients
from the food that you ate without
incorporating them into your into your
body but it's
uh
I just I feel like I know of some other
harms or risks but I can't think of
exactly what the dehydration being won
dehydration is another big one like
probably again from you know if you're
if you're a Westerner living in a modern
situation and you're not traveling it's
probably not a big risk for you but I
mean that's you're right that that even
more than uh nutrient loss is the big
the big risk if you're if you don't have
access to a lot of water yeah my guess
is the
the core of this question is somewhere
else okay
so
we do a lot of screwy things that result
in the gut Flora that we have being
more arbitrary than they should be
so it's not obvious that the isolate
that the appendix would house is a
particularly good eye slip it might be
what I'd like to know is is there a
system that the body uses to detect when
the gut is working particularly well
that it takes an isolate at that moment
and could it
if your gut Flora changed over
as a result of you encountering
something new and it was improved over
the gut Flora that had been the previous
isolate is there some mechanism for the
appendix to trade it out for the better
functioning
isolate
and I don't know that we have any
insight on this in other words I think
you know it took us long enough to get
to the obvious which was this is not a
vestigial organ this is an active organ
that is
less important for modern folks because
we're not resource stressed and so the
time period to get re-inoculated is is
irrelevant to well-being when it's not
irrelevant to well-being is the
arbitrariness of the gut flora and so
things like fecal transplants are
important but only necessary in many
cases because it is
likely that you will have very
sub-optimal gut Flora which is probably
the result of
the fact that we eat things that favor
uh the growth of one strain over another
and or other things may be entirely
missing for my diet we have no way to
get them yep
um so anyway I think there's a huge
amount of value to be had in figuring
out what the natural Ecology of the gut
is and figuring out what role the
appendix plays and
uh I I doubt that just if you didn't
change anything else just simply
inducing diary is probably not a good
idea yeah so
I mean I think I think both of these
answers are are are relevant that they
both arrive you with that answer yeah
right
ultimate answer
all right
next question from
darkhorsesmissions.com
presumably there is an optimal middle
between inbreeding and outbreeding
depression
could human aesthetic in group
preference be a cultural or epigenetic
mechanism cultural slash cultural and
epigenetic mechanism by which evolution
self-calibrates to this range
could peacock Tails have the same
purpose on the genetic level I.E
delineating lineages in a hard to forge
way
um first part of the question I would
say yes certainly by definition there
will be an optimal range but I would
point out that it is not the only
contributor
that is likely to be a factor in such
preferences in other words
as the question is delivered
the objective is optimal function right
how far from your own lineage should one
go to escape the inbreeding risks and
not to create new risks that come from
potentially combining and coherent uh
sets of genes now that latter thing is
less of a danger than you would think
right naively you might think that
that's a big danger but then if you look
at something like
domestic dogs which are really the only
competitor amongst animals that I know
of that has the same kind of range of
phenotypic variability
right you can combine any two dogs and
you get a coherent dog that means the
developmental program is capable of
taking the genes in these disparate
genomes and making them work together do
they work together
presumably some combinations work better
than others but the whole thing works
remarkably well but it's hard not to
imagine the combinations that you
probably wouldn't work
right when talking about putting
different breeds of dogs together right
but once upon a time before the
invention of the Labradoodle you might
have thought that was on the list and
yet yeah although at least they were
roughly the same size yeah
um but anyway uh
the other contributor
which does not inherently have anything
to do with function is that the genes in
a genome may be interested in getting as
many similar copies as they can and so
in other words there may be a kind of
um sexual racism that isn't about
function that is about genes doing their
own bidding that you shouldn't really
care about at the level of function my
guess is actually that's a huge fraction
of the equation
um
but it will tend to manifest like people
we've asked will tell you a cultural
story an epigenetic story about why
their preferences are what they are even
if even if it might be right something
that is uh underlaying that but you
would also Imagine
uh a there is an Untold very Politically
Incorrect story about asymmetries in
attraction in other words males who are
sexually attracted but not interested in
investing
um may be much less Discerning at this
level than
yes yeah so anyway yeah bound to be a
very Politically Incorrect story should
we ever come to discover the dimensions
of it
is that it so we're gonna stop all right
you know who Gabe Brown is
I do not doesn't ring a bell Gabe
Brown's regenerative agricultural
success in soil and fertility building
appears to disprove the uh discussion
the beaver discussion that you and Jacob
had the claims about fertility
please watch one of his lectures
but I if I don't and if you don't know
who this person is he has given a link
Brown's regenerative agricultural
success in soil fertility building
appears to disprove no I don't so I
don't from the way that question is
written I don't see how
there could be a disproof right and it
doesn't
um but I don't know all I haven't
listened to all of your conversation yet
and I don't know you know I don't know
anything about Gabe Brown so it seems
seems unlikely but um
you know and it's an hour and 40 minute
video so you know there's lots there's
lots of things we are asked to assess
and there literally aren't enough hours
in the day so yeah
we might I mean we could ask Jacob and
see if he knows yep he's ever heard of
the guy but I mean I think the basic
answer is whatever's in there or to
imagine how it disproves the beaver's
contribution to the fertile soils and uh
the depletion of modern agriculture
which
um is non-equilibrium in nature my guess
is what this guy has is an equilibrium
system or one that is uh yeah building
yeah fertility building yep um cool
awesome yeah that people and I know I
know of stories just haven't heard of
this guy
um of you know of people who have used
various techniques sure to build soil
fertility but
um alley cropping
like a-l-l-e-y like alleys well now
you're in a realm that I'm not expert in
but yes uh okay not like a woman named
Ali correct uh I remind me excuse me
what remind me what alley cropping is
yeah you grow a legume between the
target crop and you prune it into the
gullies and
effectively till it in yeah
um
yeah and letting Fields they follow and
you know Sweden and you know there's all
sorts all sorts of techniques
um I guess I don't know
claims about fertility that you or Jacob
would have made um
basically been
um our soils are depleted now and uh
beavers would help with that that's
right at the broad brush that's what I
expect the claims were right
yeah
given your understanding of the lives of
cells what do you think of chemotherapy
hmm
well let's let's first start with a
chemotherapy paradox
we had a cat die of cancer
years ago and
the cat was quite old 18 I think talking
about Sasha uh this was Abercrombie
um and anyway we had a discussion with
the vet about the possibility of
chemotherapy and it didn't make sense in
light of how old an animal this was this
was an animal at the end of his life
but what surprised me
was the chemotherapy in cats according
to the vet was
very successful and didn't have any of
the awful side effects that we know from
Human chemotherapy so that does lead to
a what the hell kind of question why
would that be yeah I will also say well
we don't know how chemotherapy in cats
differs
right like chemotherapy why should it I
mean as a general category it shouldn't
differ at all well I mean there are some
compounds that sure more so for dogs
like there's some things that can't you
know cats have a different diet than
humans there's some things that they
can't eat that we can and vice versa
sure so chemotherapy is bound to involve
many many different compounds for
different types of cancer and that's
going to be true for cats too so it's
not surprising to me that some
chemotherapy if it was different and you
could get that response in cats why
wouldn't you also get that response in
humans right and I will also say there's
another place where I see the same
style of paradox and I'm not even sure
that this one isn't just [__] but um
we seem to have a lot of trouble when we
have capital punishment finding a
combination of drugs that reliably
extinguishes the convicted person
yeah right and yet we use the nice
animals routinely
and by all appearances it is completely
effective and there's no reason in the
world that this should be any different
with a human being besides dosage
there's no reason they should be
different with a human being versus a
dog or a cat
so I kind of think it's just [__]
and um at some level we're not trying to
find those compounds and we haven't
bothered to ask a vet because
um that would be you know the cruelty is
a feature not a bug
um
so that's my cynical take but um but
anyway yep uh chemotherapy
is a bummer
I do believe that the basic premise of
kill the cancer faster than you kill the
patient is viable but that it is bound
to be it is bound to accelerate aging
across the body that's that's
that's where I think the question is
originating from right like given your
work on yeah senescence and telomeres
and such won't it cause
um distributed Aging in various cellular
lineages across the body or at least
anywhere the chemo hits yeah yep it will
right and I will say
um
someone we know and love had a breast
cancer had it removed and had a kind of
therapy not chemo but radiation that
struck me as extremely clever where
instead of the problem with radiation is
if you have a beam of radiation it goes
through the patient right all the way
through the healthy tissues and the
suspect tissues
um in this person's case they embedded
temporarily the radioactive element so
it could irradiated the surrounding
tissue you get like the exponential
decay like it's right it's right at
source where it needs to be and you know
is it getting into a little little bit
into a little bit of healthy tissue yes
but it was so localized it was just
barely and in fact I forget which kind
of Decay it is if it's beta Decay but
there's one of the kinds of the memory
that doesn't penetrate very far yeah
um and so anyway this struck me as very
elegant it took something that is uh
Draconian medically Draconian and made
it you know yeah trivially bad no and
this is I mean this was cutting edge in
I guess this probably would have been
2014.
um and still feels like wow I'm amazed
that we can do that yeah it's a great
technology and in principle there is no
reason you couldn't do something like
this with chemo where the idea is that
something that breaks down uh is
embedded or probably better more to the
point you could use something like uh
monoclonal antibodies that are
specifically programmed for your
chemical idiosyncrasies of your cancer
to basically float around and not stick
to you and then stick to the cancer and
deliver the um the chemical toxin right
to the location I know that that's the
kind of thing that people have been
playing with for years so I don't know
that it's ever come to fruition or not
but
um chemotherapy bad
there are probably tricks to doing away
this is the best possibility oh yeah in
lots of cases absolutely I will say that
there is a general issue
with
doctors will often elect not to take
um
therapies for something like cancer that
they would advise their patients to take
in some sense the bias in medicine is
you know
you know the patient is frightened and
doesn't want to die it's advised to
treat yeah because not treating seems
like a
it invites litigation well it invites
litigation and
um it also you know you have somebody
terrified in your office so you've just
told you know that they have a tumor and
that you know it's it's fatal and the
desire to live longer is completely
understandable but the question is there
is a trade-off between quality of life
and length of life and unless you've
thought about that issue carefully ahead
of time then you know grasping for more
life it makes sense but a doctor who's
seen the cost up close may have a very
different sense about whether it's worth
it yeah and I will point out that very
you can't measure quality of life really
but it seems like the analysis here is
uh in some of these cases
the best case scenario might be you have
100 units of quality of life and you can
experience those hundred units over two
years or over one year yeah right and
you know do you want to have a better
one year or a half as good two years
starting now yeah right absolutely and I
will say that this is not about chemo or
treatment but
Norm MacDonald's death I think is a
topic that just does not get enough
attention I don't remember the
circumstances well the circumstances I
don't remember anything medically
unremarkable
um he
was diagnosed with cancer
and it was terminal
and I will tell you I actually
interacted with him over Unity he was
interested he expressed some interest
and I was like hey can we get you on
board can we have you on a podcast
something like that yeah and he was like
I don't know right he didn't want to do
it and I did not know at the time that
he was terminally ill but of course
nobody knew that he was terminally ill
because he literally he did yeah he
literally didn't tell anyone yeah and
the the reason I think that that's
important
is that he availed himself of a kind of
value
that most people bypass where he got to
live the end of his life without cancer
being the story right he actually you
know okay you've got a certain number of
months to to live or a year to live and
the point is well I'd actually like to
just have it yeah I don't want everybody
who interacts with me to be thinking oh
was this the last time I'm going to see
you right I just want it to be normal
that's what I want as another year of
normal life or something like that and
so anyway I I don't know what the answer
is but it did strike me as a this was a
very intelligent guy right
also very unusual and that he did
something very unusual at the end of his
life yeah
um was profound that's fascinating I
don't I I've forgotten that if I knew it
um
I'm recalling
I think some other famous person who
obscured from her family and loved ones
that she was sick
until until either she was gone or like
she had two days left or something
and
I don't remember any of the details even
who it was but as I remember it there
was at least one of her close of her
friends who thought of herself as very
close anyway which may be part of the
story here who was Furious
he said I I wanted to be able to say
goodbye how you know how how dare you
keep me
from being able to say goodbye and I
thought
oh but I I believe that what you got
instead was a number of interactions
with your friend
and
you know it may be that there is
something
that she needed to say I think it was
two women in this case
um that she really felt she needed to
say in which case
if I mean if you have those things you
should figure out a way to say them you
should figure out a way to say them
rather than know that like you're
definitely going to want to do this
before either of you die because
obviously that could happen to anyone at
any moment
um and it also felt like you know at
some level it was a a way to be angry at
the situation and appear to be angry at
the at the now dead friend rather than
going through your grief yeah or as part
of your grief but
it felt like it misunderstood the value
in the decision uh and it and it as I
remember it it was presented as there
was only one right thing to have done
here you owe it to inform the world when
you get a diagnosis like this
and I thought no no you do not I mean
and in part I'm able to come to that
conclusion very easily because so many
of these diagnoses are only possible
because of very recent technological
developments and so you wouldn't know
and if there's a situation which you
wouldn't know and if there's any part of
you that wishes you didn't know you
certainly don't owe it
to everyone else
to inform them right and you know the
other part of you you
definitely said it but I think it
should be emphasized which is to the
extent that you think you have a right
to know uh
life-ending diagnosis that somebody
receives because you have things you
need to say to them
those are things you need to say and you
you know the idea that you're waiting
until you know somebody's on the way out
is preposterous you know
um so those are not easy conversations
to have
but I am a fan of the idea that you
should keep accounts current
yeah
I mean I guess there are of course
things in some in some relationships and
some families
that you don't want a person to be
living with
yeah but you feel for what I
I'm not coming up with an example right
now and we're lucky not to have this
yeah
um
but where you feel like actually
although I guess most most of the time
that's yeah it goes the other way it's I
don't I don't want to live with this
knowledge in the universe but it
yeah it should be out there now that I'm
not around to have to deal with it or
three percussions whatever it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah no I do think it usually
goes the other way yeah um
that wasn't really about chemotherapy
but no we got there no we started there
yeah
any thoughts so I don't recognize the
name of the
the company but I I know this plan
um any thoughts on colossal trying to
bring back the woolly mammoth a cold
resistant elephant with the core
biological traits of the woolly mammoth
https colossal.com thank you
um
last I checked into this
they weren't actually claiming to bring
back the woolly mammoth which of course
they can't and so you know you and I got
energized about this probably a decade
ago like what did they can't be doing
what they claim to be doing like who's
not telling the truth where
and if you look at their fine print I
don't even what are they doing well
they've got fragments of a genome and so
yeah and they're gonna put they get
fragments of Holy Mountain genome into
its closest living relative right yeah
what is probably going to be an African
elephant be my guess
um but
I don't think that's a terrific idea but
it's also not bringing back the woolly
mammoth and what what irritates me the
most there is the
audacity in combination with the lying
about it because if you if you're
actually if you're knowledgeable enough
to attempt this and think that you have
any chance of success you know that what
you're doing is not bringing back the
woolly mammoth yeah and yet that is
clearly the story by which they're
getting all the Press yep
well I'd be more excited I mean I'd be
excited if you could bring back a woolly
mammoth
it's not on the menu of possibilities
here whether the thing that is on the
menu of possibilities is worth doing or
fair to the animal especially in light
of the fact that it's a highly
intelligent yes
um critter
but uh
I would want to pygmy stegodon elephant
that's what I want from Flores uh from
it's not this is that's one of the the
microfana that we're on Flores yeah
Indonesia the dwarfed
island with homo fluoresciensis the very
short statured hominins yeah but I mean
wouldn't it be cool to have a pygmy stag
it on how much how how big were they
actually oh like a cow
you're hoping for like putting an
elephant door and have them go
and go I would totally do that for a big
mistake I don't know if I would wouldn't
you yes I would yes I really would
um I think I would name him Bob sure
yeah that makes sense nah sure does
okay next question
we are well tuned to the danger posed by
scary tribes for instance Islam and
trumpers this person offers is the scary
tribes but are often blind to the danger
posed by institutions for instance the
FBI and Pfizer Etc to what do you
attribute the societal blind spot
I feel like we're just talking about
this last night with Jacob actually
um about
you know
the idea that you should
we all think we're looking for enemies
and the enemies come in the form of
individuals or in groups made up of
individuals as opposed to organizations
and yes you could frame an organization
as a group made up of an individual but
the distinction is important the
distinction is basically Goliath
versus possible Davids
yeah I do think there's something
there's something about the novelty of
Institutions I mean obviously
institutions
didn't exist in any meaningful sense
fifteen thousand years ago
and populations have and populations
look like groups so even if a group you
know
is also novel it's a novel in a form
that we sort of expected
um
but I also I think there's a banality of
evil
Point here too
which is that it's hard to model
because you are a member of a group
you can model group dynamics you've seen
them you've experienced them you've
participated in them you've initiated
them
you may or may not be part of an
institution if you're part of an
institution you may be you know oh I
keep my head down and do my job and I
don't think too much about how the
institution works right
um so it's much harder to have an
accurate enough model to be useful
and so we don't we don't spend time
modeling it because it's not productive
and that I think that is upending people
like uh
like Sam
right you know he dismissed a huge
amount of what turned out to be right on
the basis that it was conspiratorial and
it's like well
damn uh yes it is but it's not an
argument it's not an argument right
exactly well
to the degree that it is it requires
being explicit about the assumption that
if conspiracy is part of your
explanation I have taken that off the
table as even possibly true
because if people are honorable and
honest and complete
as clear thinkers should be about
knowing on what basis the foundations of
their argument are resting like how how
axiomatic can you go what are the
assumptions what are the axioms like
what how
how can you reduce as much as possible
the assumptions that you are making
about the universe and then and and list
them
and then let's start
and if one of your starting points is
conspiracy never happens which appears
to be uh that I I think that that is
just a linguistic reframing of the
position that if it's a conspiracy then
you're crazy
right like I will not consider anything
involving conspiracy isn't that the same
thing as saying that conspiracy doesn't
happen and if that's an assumption you
need to make that really clear and that
needs to be part of every framing
of the argument going forward I don't
think that's I mean clearly if we took
if we took it literally then it is but I
don't think
[Music]
no intelligent person thinks conspiracy
doesn't happen you couldn't think that
because there are too many cases in
which conspiracies have been so what is
it here conspiracy in this this case
under these conditions like what it's
then then it's not even an assumption
level there's still there's a whole lot
of baggage but I think it's
um
Fringe perspectives are wrong
okay Fringe perspectives are wrong is
obviously wrong
but if you're faced with a fringe
perspective
It's usually the right way to bet
cringe perspectives are wrong as a
winner more often than it's a loser so
it's taking a
statistically reliable gambling strategy
and mistaking it for truth right it's
and you know if you squint at it right
it's hill climbing versus Valley
Crossing
in the language of adaptive Landscapes
right so the point is you can tend to go
uphill by betting Against The Fringe
perspective it's typically correct and
so you'll go uphill but if you're stuck
on a low Peak it ain't going to get you
to a Higher One
um and so anyway I think it's that
people are feeling clever because
they've gone uphill it's like yeah the
weird you know you know yes that Hill is
eroding and you've yes gotten yourself
back to the top of it again but you
haven't done anything about the rate of
erosion
um
yeah and so anyway you know it to me
it's a red flag right like at least what
is the claim that something is incorrect
because it's conspiratorial
yeah no I mean that claim
can be reframed as I said it and yes
anyone almost any one reason will say no
obviously sometimes happens but like if
really what you're claiming is that's
not true because it's conspiratorial
then you've made yourself impossible to
argue with in any way and and it's
unfalsifiable yeah but it's it's even
worse because effectively
you uh in so doing you're making a
little profit right I get it that you're
making a profit but you're also signing
us up for an existential threat that we
don't have to face right if you want to
feel smug about staring down conspiracy
theories and dismissing them without any
consideration I get why you feel smug
but I think your smugness is going to
get us killed and it's a little like
saying you know kennicides don't happen
yeah usually they don't but they do
sometimes and if you say [__] like
genocides don't happen you're gonna get
us into one right you're gonna ignore
one that's happening because you you
feel clever noticing that it's not
you're going to get us into one not that
it's not possible but much more you will
miss the signs when one does show up
yeah you are gonna get us into one one
is going to be coming and you're gonna
say something clever about not worrying
about it since genocides aren't real and
my point is
listen
they're rare
when one is coming there's nothing more
important than knowing that that's
what's going on right so don't you dare
sign me up for something that solves a
problem you know
364 days a year that's not what I want I
want something that airs in the
direction of spotting the damn thing
when it's happening because nothing is
more important at that moment
yeah and sometimes
the trade-off is sometimes there will be
concern when there wasn't reason for
concern yep that is the trade-off well
and you know those of us who
want to err in the other direction so
we're sure and know that we make that
error are not you know we're not
dimwitted in the other direction right
we recognize that there's a problem that
comes with talking about conspiracies
right it's not easy screws with Occam's
razor right and that's
that is a problem
right but there are some people who
figured out how to do it well and that's
that's really the question yep
1770 this is just a statement
1776. we hold these truths to be
self-evident 2023 experts hold these
truths to be malinformation
very nice it's very very good it's nice
and I don't want to save that maybe I'll
frame it
um
how to deal with devaluation of the PHD
Title by people who get it in novel
areas of woke science and with a
distrust in real scientists
well the problem is older than that
you're gonna need a time machine and
you're gonna have to have a very
compelling argument you're gonna have to
reach a large number of people quickly I
think it's just too late I think the
point is
if you don't realize that a PhD means
nothing at this point
you're not paying attention and you know
it is Downstream of them having handed
it out for non-work you know for poetry
that masquerading as science and all
sorts of things well but I mean
you get a PhD in something yep so
you know you I think in poetry you
should be an MFA but um say a PhD in
literature it should mean something and
it does not mean the same thing as a PhD
in biology which also doesn't mean the
same thing as a PhD in mathematics
but more to the point I think like
whether or not there is any consistency
to what exactly uh literature versus
biology versus math PhD means
um
between
institutions
between decades
between mentors
there's almost no consistency and I
don't that doesn't that doesn't even
require an ideology to have taken over
that doesn't require fake disciplines it
doesn't require whole institutions
failing because they can't figure out
how to say no to a mob Etc it's just
about the variation and then you know
having you know just like
most faculty are trying to reduce the
amount of time they have to spend
teaching because they don't think of it
as their real work and so therefore most
college faculty aren't that amazing with
students
it's different with grad students you
know people are more uh are more
rewarded for and Hope usually by having
solid relationships with grad students
but that can also become a distraction
to what people consider their real work
and so putting people on it like okay
just you know oh you're in my lab just
do this project
right in in biology
with you know people who are smart and
well intended very often will end up
with you know phds without ever having
had to frame their own hypothesis or
figure out what the experiment might be
right and like that you know
not having done a complete piece of
science
um but having a PhD in a science is
quite remarkable and that's still a hell
of a lot better than a lot of what is
happening in Academia
yeah but I still think at the end of the
day I'm not saying nobody who has a PHD
is an expert in anything obviously but
what I am saying is that the fact that
somebody has a PHD is now inherently
meaningless not only is it inherently
meaningless because of woke Insanity
which has done something special where
in order to get a PhD you probably have
to agree to things that are false right
that's probably new
um but the funding structure of
universities that handed these things
out in lieu of
money right uh to induce people to do
the work of the university to free the
pis to get the grants that thing
meant that you had a lot of people who
were basically had an honorary degree in
exchange for laboring right that wrecked
the damn thing
um the income inconsistency between
mentors that contributed to it
but you know we just watched
all the experts
screw up the most important thing on
earth and in unison say nonsense right
so
I think that demonstrates that whatever
you know it may be a complex cocktail of
things but whatever that complex
cocktail is in the face of puzzles that
were
um
manifestly comprehensible yeah
um no and you're not you're talking
about people with phds in you know
traditional established real disciplines
yep so I mean that's consistent with
what I said you don't you don't have to
go
to the made-up disciplines like that
that is obviously making adding adding
fuel to the fire
but it's a
we both said this so many places so many
ways like you can't just scrape the
ideology off the top this this new
ideology which is at risk of destroying
you know everything itself
but scrape it off the top and it will
return in some other form unless you fix
the underlying structures yeah yeah and
it's possible that you know
PhD is just done because you know once
you've once you've created a zillion of
these things that mean nothing then you
know does it make sense to resurrect it
or does it make some sense to build
something new that actually does mean
something where where you can set a
standard and you're not
um you're not beholden to some long
history that is now a joke
why do most people cringe at the sound
of fingernails on a chalkboard
and why do some but not most cringe at
the sound of thin plastic being crumpled
I've never heard this in plastic one
it's wrong it's not it's just wrong our
producer says it's just wrong
I don't know I'm not sure I'm not sure
what it's a reference I think she knows
wherever she speaks uh this uh the
person who's asking the question but I
I've never heard it um but the but the
sound of females on the chalkboard is
obviously something that many of us I I
always wonder how can you not how can
you not cringe yeah and I have no
reaction to it yeah I wouldn't say what
kind of alien are you uh
um
rhetorical yeah I know I'm I'm getting
there I am such an unusual person that I
went 20 000 consecutive days without uh
gender flipping so
apparently
at least plausibly that immunizes you to
um
no because I've gone almost like not
quite as many shy 65 days those are the
those are the key days really
So within the next unfortunately that
makes a prediction over the next two
months I too will not have a reaction to
fingernails on a chalkboard yeah
um no I don't I don't know uh let's put
it this way I don't have a reaction if
you go up to a chalkboard and you do
that thing doesn't bug me even just like
that yeah
um if somebody I'm in a whiteboard sure
a supremely white board
[Laughter]
if somebody is drawing like back in
grade school
remember when they would draw the
what is it a dashed line and in between
the two lines so you could also you
learn your cursive or something exactly
yeah and so you remember they had a
thing that would allow them to draw
those things on the board and every so
often it would go wrong it would go
I don't think I ever went to a school
with those I think they were written
onto the board permanently it's like the
boards have permanent makeup whoa
well in any case every so often somebody
screws up at a chalkboard yeah and it
goes and that does doesn't
it alarms me it doesn't it's not like it
and that makes me jump a little bit but
um but no the fingernails are so much
worse I think I imagine them being
ripped off
yeah it's going the wrong way
yeah they do yeah so that's what Zach
and I have arrived at because it seems
like uh they will
start peeling off so it's the the
discomfort is not in your ear it's in
your mouth it's like imagining somebody
falling off a bike or something yeah
imagine you have a piece of sheet metal
I do and you have a flat so you're at
Home Depot it's like a flat concrete
floor and you push it along that yeah
it's gonna be just fine no it doesn't
sound like it sounds great okay it's
just fine until it hits some little bump
and it the whole thing buckles and it's
terrible yeah it doesn't sound bad it
doesn't because it's not your own
fingers but you it brings up that sort
of an image of what at the point do you
hit something that it pulls it too far
yeah and actually it's interesting I
just cut my nails and I don't really I
can imagine that and it's not that bad
oh but if I haven't just cut my nails
it's terrible it's awful oh that's so
try this at home actually that's
fascinating see if you're if you are one
of the people like most of us who aren't
aliens who have this reaction to
imagining Nails in a chalkboard see if
you're see if your visceral response is
different before and after you cut your
nails that is fascinating Zach yeah
because I like I thought that I would
love to do that with the chalkboard
right now but it certainly wouldn't
bother me tremendously because there's
no leverage there's no leverage on it
yeah it would just be basically the very
edge of the nail and there's nothing
that can really go wrong that's
interesting I guess I'm trying to think
so I mean my nails are always short but
they're not nearly as short as they were
when I was playing two hours of piano a
day for many years when they had to be
very very short and I guess a prediction
here would be that during those eight
years or whatever of my childhood I
didn't have a stronger reaction either
right interesting yeah I like it
uh that I thought all you people were
freaking out because it hurt your ears
experience like in the experiences it
messes like you really can't take the
noise
but it's because like I can deal with
noise just fine right now but if I go a
month it's gonna be so another another
noise
another test that could be done is
make a sound that's that
two versions I guess that sound but
compel the person that is being that is
it is being played to that it is a
different sound like come up with
something that sounds very much like it
and tell them this is this is something
entirely different and see if they have
the same reaction and try to fully
replicate it such that it really isn't
that yeah and tell them that it isn't
and see if see if they react the same I
also just realized that if I I since I
literally just cut my nails they're so
short that if I did that on a chalkboard
it actually wouldn't make the same sound
it just could just be my finger pads I
don't know I can get the nails on it but
it would just be like
two slightly abrasive surfaces just
rubbing against each other it's very
different from the like you get a little
bit of resonance if you have nails that
are anywhere and it does it does risk
shattering like sheet metal on a
concrete floor like you can hit
something and yeah no no it's very very
uncomfortable if you have even just like
two millimeters of nail past the end of
your fingers it's another one of my
superpowers not giving a damn about that
noise
it's like Kryptonite for you folks Am I
Wrong oh wow yeah a little bit a little
bit a little better I don't know about
the thin plastic being crumpled though
never heard that one yeah me either
probably not surprising because they're
part of the TNI
a trusted news initiative probably not
surprising because they're part of the
TNI but when I voice search Google for
darkhorsesubmissions.com none of the
results on the first page point to the
actual site no I don't think that's
it
um
I wonder if Contracting a virus and
surviving is not a net positive for
evolution why are we interpreting
viruses as threats versus natural
processes maybe we are suppressing
nature
yeah
or yeah I I doubt this well and there's
just the devil's going to be in the
details of what the virus is yeah I mean
and to the extent that it is not the
case then the immune system will not
resist and so we may not notice it right
so to the extent that there is truth in
what is being said here the point is
it's probably a cryptic phenomenon and
there is a lot of integration of viruses
into genomes and things like that so
anyway when we fight it's probably
because it's not good to be infected but
at the the bottom layer
a viral infection involves your cells
doing the bidding of some other creature
and it's very hard for that to be
mutualistic because your immune system
will regard the production of that
foreign stuff as an indicator that the
cells need to be killed which will
accelerate the Aging of whatever tissue
they were in so you know accelerating
aging is just it's damage yeah and I
guess um you know the end of the
sentence the way it's phrased you know
threats versus natural processes it's
both right there's plenty of things that
are both and so I think that the
question you know maybe a way of
suppressing nature well yeah because uh
we can't all just get along equally you
know there there is vying for limited
resources and uh we engage in that vying
in lots of different ways uh but more
often than not exactly as you are
pointing to a virus that is trying to
infect a human body uh is a competitor
at some level
and sometimes it's a going to be a
long-term competitor that we can't know
the implications of yeah
just because it's natural doesn't mean
it's good
how does one cope with and combat the
curse of Cassandra and the feelings of
hopelessness that come with it or are
they just doomed to failure
I thought I heard you say cursive
Cassandra
the curse of Cassandra yeah Cassandra
was cursed by Zeus I want to say Maybe
not maybe I've got the wrong
mythological Universe
um
to tell the truth and never be believed
right my parents were going to name me
Cassandra and decided not to because
they didn't want to bestow upon me the
curse of Cassandra but here we are here
we are 2023.
um yeah so the curse of Cassandra is
somebody who warns of the demise of
cursive and is not listened to
um
do you go on no I'm that's I'm just but
the actual question right
um
so the the question is
how do we deal with it uh there are a
lot of us who are truth-telling and
attempting to truth tell and to some
degree we know
we know that we've been right about
stuff that has been not believed that
people are coming up with reasons and
excuses to not believe it still even
when the evidence mounts how to deal
with it
well and you know how to how to cope
with it and also how to
fight against the curse and to you know
be more believed when you're really
trying to do the right thing I think the
son of a [__] has handed us a terrible
um weapon in this battle
which is that lots of people in fact I
noticed
uh during the brief break between the
main podcast on the Q a that
um
why am I forgetting Dilbert's uh Creator
Scott Adams
um put out a video in which he said can
we all agree that the anti-vaxxers which
he doesn't really mean anti-vaxxers he
means people who didn't get the coveted
vaccines were right at least at this
point what
um Scott Adams yeah
anyway I mean it's been his point I
watched most of his video his point was
look uh if you're not vaccinated for
covid then you don't have to worry about
what damage that thing did and you know
I I think this every time I get my heart
heart rate up doing something is thank
goodness I don't have to worry about
whether or not there's a hidden
time bomb in the wall of my heart you
know that kind of thing
um
so anyway
the
answer is
you don't want to be
in that predicament something caused a
lot of people to do stuff that many of
them now regret having done
so the point is this was never an
abstract discussion this was not a
classroom exercise to see who could
Marshal the cleverest arguments this was
really an argument about what you as an
individual should or should not do and
all of us who were adults at the time
that this happened had a choice
are you gonna take the thing or you're
not gonna take the thing or are you
gonna take this version of the thing and
not that version of the thing right
those were all choices and the point is
look certain people got this right some
of them might have gotten it right by
accident that is possible but some of
them seem to have a track record
maybe at the point that you get to the
place where you're now regretting and
altering your choice so that it's you
don't do it to yourself again the point
is well geez you know I thought I should
be listening to the CDC and The Who
turned out that didn't work out and then
there were some people I didn't think I
should be listening to and now I'm doing
what they did and so
maybe next time at least I'm not going
to go in there reflexively listening to
the CDC and the who I'm going to listen
to the people who seem to figure out how
to navigate the evidence
so anyway I think that's kind of where
we are is that we're we we it's too easy
to forget
that
this isn't a done deal and it was never
abstract this was about real stuff and
people are now
if they're thinking
they are retracing their steps and
hopefully the point is well you know
can I introduce you to Cassandra because
she had it right you know that kind of
thing
yeah
in your opinions what will be the state
of Academia in 10 years time
it's either going to be limping along
more brittle and fragile and uninspired
than ever
or there will have been
one or three or five or eight
forays into something new actually
really new
uh that are anti-fragile and uh you know
bring us back into a state of at least
having a system of higher ed that has a
chance of brokering knowledge in this
bizarrely quickly evolving world
yeah so I will I will try
um to add a few more steps in here
think we have now poisoned the well
so that there is no meaning in the
degree that somebody walks away with and
that those who are trying to accomplish
something employers who want to hire
somebody competent
are going to catch on to this pattern
that they can't uh they can't detect
somebody's level of capacity
um
based on their academic record and
they're going to start hiring people
based on proxies and those who are good
at it are going to figure out what
proxies are actually meaningful and so
you're going to get a kind of
Gold Rush to find the people who aren't
academic don't have a CV or a degree or
whatever but show the Hallmarks of
capacity
and as that happens no reasonable person
is going to send their offspring to
these institutions these institutions
are going to be starved for people who
want to do something technical or want
to do science right anything hard-headed
is not going to work
and these institutions can't survive on
the woke nonsense Fields right those
nonsense Fields don't bring in the the
money and so they will fall apart
and that is what will fuel a boom in
alternative institutions and so maybe
this is wishful thinking but I hope that
the collapse of those institutions as a
result of their own greed and idiocy
will
um take out the accreditation system
along with it and free people who
understand the importance of a proper
educational system
to build one From the Ashes and I would
point out that that does mean that there
will be an awful lot of campuses
that have no purpose but have wonderful
buildings in which you could
put books and hold classes and things
like that so I won't be surprised if the
new University system ends up in the
buildings of the old one and if there
isn't some cryptic changeover but
something like that yeah
okay one story and one last question and
then we're out okay
uh
I believe that memo at the beginning
here means mammogram I had a mammogram
yesterday
offered me a mask I said no thanks she
told me it's required I walked the F out
this was after early check-in where they
asked me my assigned sex at Birth and
current gender
if I'm right this was a mammogram it's a
mamo m-a-mmo
current gender that's in keeping with
the silliness
um assigned sex at Birth and a mammogram
right
that's great
that's amazing
wow so good
it's one word for it
no it's I mean it's perfect right it is
evidence that the system is completely
devoid of meaning
oh you've just given birth and are you
the mother of the father
[Laughter]
right
that's it's great
I love it I mean if you know if we're
gonna do this stupidity let's go all the
way let's go all in completely
transparently stupid yep yep yep
oh and that was from someone who's give
whose name was I finally caught up with
it Malin formation
Mallon formation yeah okay one last
question why is it the farm chickens
that get bird flu are all destroyed
instead of discovering survivors and
breeding those resistant Birds
probably because it would take longer is
like I don't know anything about you
know gigantic commercial chicken
breeding operations except that they're
horrible but my guess is that it's a
simple uh
simple short-sighted economic decision
whereas
from what little I know it does seem
like letting selection do its job and
taking the resistant Birds would be a
better move
yeah it is I mean I think you would need
like a second facility that's it depends
on how how contagious it is how virulent
it is yeah if you prepare well
problem is in because bird flu is
transmissible to people the idea of
preserving birds that appear to be
resistant
yeah runs the risk that you are present
yeah exactly that kind of yeah yeah yeah
okay maybe that's maybe that's the
answer
that's where we'll end all right maybe
that's the answer maybe this has been
maybe that's the answer we've got
another
right
um
cool well uh we will see you next week
if you're here and if you're not uh find
us later yeah but consider sharing
subscribing liking all that good stuff
uh on any wherever it is that you find
our our stuff we've got Dark Horse
Channel channels now at all the major
social media sites and um
yeah I don't know if they have anything
else we're there so until we see you
next time be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
foreign